how evil you think you think he's an  evil guy  yeah i do and i but i also think there  are uh a lot of people who we look up to  who  anyone from the other side of the the  river would say oh that's an evil  mountain  i think he's evil i i can understand why  people don't but  there's a there's a quote that  when you murder people  yeah well there's a quote that um i saw  on the lex fredman podcast i don't  remember the name but the guy said  listen some great men  are not necessarily good men  and  there's no doubt that he is a cunning  political figure to stay at the top of  russian politics for the better half of  two decades and then some when you could  easily just have a drink of a cocktail  and end up dead  he's got to be  don't  undermine i'm not saying you but don't  undermine how savvy of a political  figure this man is